since Germanness admonished for Tagen to
turn to the true god and abstain from
all unlawful intercourse with his
daughter but the unhappy wretch fled for
refuge to the province Gothica name so
called from his own name where he
concealed himself with his wives but st.
Germanness followed him with all the
British clergy and upon a rock prayed
for his sins
during forty days and forty nights
[Music]
the Blessed man was unanimously chosen
commander against the Saxons and then
not by the clang of trumpets but by
praying singing
hallelujah and the cries of the army to
God the enemies were routed and driven
even to the sea again water gone
ignominiously flew from st. geminus to
the kingdom of the Dimity we're on the
river towie he built a castle which he
named keg witha gayen the saint as usual
followed him there and with his clergy
fasted and prayed to the Lord three days
and as many nights on the third night at
the third hour fire fell suddenly from
heaven and totally burnt the castle
wrought again the daughter of Hengist
his other wives and all the inhabitants
both men and women miserably perished
and was the end of this unhappy King as
we find written in the life of Saint
Germanness others assured us that being
hated by all the people of Britain for
having received the Saxons and being
publicly charged by Saint geminus and
the clergy in the sight of God Hiba took
himself the flight and that deserted and
a wanderer he sought a place of refuge
till brokenhearted he made an
ignominious spend some accounts state
that the earth opened and swallowed him
up on the night his castle was burned
and the remains were discovered the
following morning either of him or of
those who were burned with him he had
three sons the eldest was Baltimore who
as we have seen Ford four times against
the Saxons and put them to flight the
second category who was slain in the
same battle with Horsa the third was
Pass Kent who reigned in the two
provinces will thand or thicker named
after the death of his father
these were granted him by Ambrosius
who's the great king among the kings of
Britain the fourth was Faustus born of
incest Lluis marriage with his daughter
who was brought up and educated by seint
jame us he builds a large monastery on
the banks of the river Ennis called
after his name which remains to the
present period enough has been said of
water and Saint Germanness after his
death returned in day's own country at
that time the Saxons greatly increased
in Britain both in strength and numbers
and octa after the death of his father
Hengist came from the sinestro part of
the island to the Kingdom of Kent and
from him have preceded all the kings of
that province to the present period then
it was that the magnanimous Arthur with
all the kings and military force of
Britain fought against the Saxons and
though there were many more noble than
himself yet he was twelve times chosen
their commander and was often Conqueror
the first battle in which he was engaged
was at the mouth of the river galini the
second third fourth and fifth were on
another river by the Britons called
Douglas in the region
Linnaeus the sixth on the river basis
the seventh in the wood called-- on
which the Britons called cat koi Khalid
on the eighth was near gurney and castle
where Arthur wore the image of the Holy
Virgin Mother of God upon his shoulders
and through the power of our Lord Jesus
Christ and the Holy Mary put the Saxons
to flight and pursued them the whole day
with great slaughter
ix was at the city of Legion which is
called care Lyon the tenth was on the
bank of the river trash trail right
the 11th was on the mountain brer going
which we call cat Gregg Ian the 12th was
a most severe contest
when Arthur penetrated the hill of Baden
in this engagement 940 fell by his hand
alone no one but the Lord affording him
assistance and all these engagements the
Britons were successful for no strength
can avail against the will of the
almighty the more the Saxons were
vanquished the more they sought for new
supplies of Saxons from Germany so that
Kings commanders and military bands were
invited over from almost every province
and his practice they continued till the
reign of EDA who was the son of a OPA he
of the saxon race who was the first King
in Bern akia and in ke broke when
grissini cuantas was consulate rome
because then the whole world was
governed by the Roman consuls the Saxons
were received by water-gun in the year
of our Lord 447 and to the year in which
we now write 547 and whosoever shall
read here in may receive instruction the
Lord Jesus Christ are falling assistants
who Coe eternal with the father and the
Holy Ghost lives and reigns forever and
ever
our men
[Music]
[Music]